un día antes del aniversario del inicio
de la guerra en Ucrania kiev siguen su
papel de anfitrión con la maquinaria
diplomática bien engrasada durante la
semana el presidente bolodimir selenski
había recibido a su homólogo
estadounidense Joe biden y a la primera
ministra de Italia Georgia meloni y el
jueves ha sido el turno para Pedro
Sánchez presidente del gobierno de
España quien prometió el envío de seis
tanques leopardos Y quizá hasta diez
reconocemos que Ucrania necesita nuestro
apoyo en estos momentos y se lo
proporcionaremos ya hemos enviado todo
tipo de municiones vehículos y armas
pero entendemos que se necesita más para
contener a Rusia y recuperar el
territorio ocupado
alta actividad diplomática que llega a
China justo después de la visita de
wangi principal diplomático de Beijing a
Moscú el portavoz de exteriores One
wending envió un mensaje a Washington
instamos a Estados Unidos a que deje de
difamar y echar la culpa deje de avivar
las llamas y trabaje con China y la
comunidad internacional para promover
conjuntamente las negociaciones
diplomáticas para resolver la crisis
pero más allá del plano diplomático el
simbólico el presidente de Rusia
Vladimir Putin hizo una ofrenda floral
en el día del defensor de la patria
también en lugans una de las cuatro
regiones bajo control ruso partidarios
de Moscú salieron en caravana a
conmemorar la fecha esto el mismo día en
el que se abrió el puente de kerch que
da acceso a crimea y que había sufrido
una explosión en octubre de 2022
Mientras tanto Ucrania prepara efectivos
para el campo de batalla con soldados
entrenándose en Reino Unido para poder
usar los tanques Challenger y cerca de
kiev su alcalde vitalisco supervisó un
ejercicio de defensa situación distinta
a la de bahamut contra la que lejos de
entrenamientos continúan los ataques
rusos
en su objetivo de hacerse con un punto
clave de la región de donia